all right so
out of this beautiful spread and
beautiful bounty what are we making
today and how can we learn from you so
it's my own little spin on shakshuka so
shakshuka is a moroccan dish it's a
breakfast dish with tomato sauce and
some eggs in it so we switched it up at
the grocer and we made a zatar shakshuka
so what we're going to do is mix a
little zatar and olive oil which we
already have mixed but i'll add a little
bit of olive oil to it and we're going
to mix that up and then we've got our
and can you give a little like flavor
profile to this spice is it reminiscent
of certain something so zottar has
oregano thyme
marjoram
sesame seeds and sumac in it so it's
herbaceous but also this like
the sumac makes it a little tangy as
well so it's a little bit of both and
what we're going to do now that it's
bubbling we're going to crack the eggs
right in there and the zatra paste is
basically gonna fry up the eggs
so
all i've been thinking about is crack
your eggs correctly onto oh my gosh
here we go
i'm not kidding eddie i just did the
exact same thing i was like oh no i'm
gonna have to mess this up
so we're gonna crack those right in here
and you can see the eggs are gonna start
bubbling up and frying in the zatar
paste and it gives it like that
delicious crust
and then
we're going to let that go
and let that zatar piece kind of do its
own
job right in there look at
nice nice i don't want to let you down
i'm going to do this
so while that's that's doing its thing
we're going to get our halloumi going so
are you familiar with halloumi i am a
huge lumihead i love halloumi um so for
you that don't know what halloumi is it
is a cheese that you can sear and cook
because it doesn't melt so we're going
to throw some olive oil into our pan
and then we're going to just sear off
the halloumi and um what is the tomato
jam so how and where does that play so
basically you would sear the halloumi
which is why i love this pan that we're
using and you would sear the halloumi
and then throw the tomatoes right in
there with the garlic and let that all
cook together but instead we've made it
on the side and it's bubbling and we're
going to add that right into the pan the
tomato paste yes once the halloumi is
ready
once the halloumi is ready
halloumi
so i'm gonna add the other
halloumi right in there
and then just
throw this delicious tomato jam right on
top
and the great thing about this tomato
jam i like to call it a tomato jam but
it's just really to like cherry tomatoes
with garlic cooked down and do you cut
your cherry tomatoes first like in half
or you just let them let them burst on
their own that's when you know they're
ready oh yeah we've all done some
bursting on our own here and there
so we're just gonna let that go
let it do its thing uh oh what happened
to this egg eddie um
i don't know my eggs are looking oh oh
what that what alien species happened
there
it's like poaching basically in the
zatar it really is so should i grab the
non-alien egg yes and stick them in um
so what we're going to do is actually
now that it's ready we're just going to
plate up okay yeah so
do you have a plate i do have a plate um
i might need a plate also i might oh you
know what here i'm a rebel homemaker
there we go what do i do
so what we're going to do is i'm going
to turn this down a little we're going
to serve ourselves
a little the tomato jam
with some halloumi
of course i'm gonna have two pieces of
halloumi because why not
and then
we're gonna put some of the egg right in
here as well
so you know that the egg is ready once a
that crust becomes crunchy around it so
i i mean i might be a rebel homemaker
but i
do care about plating yes
all right and then the egg is over one
of my eggs one of the eggs an alien
species and then maybe a little bit of
arugula on top just for a little green
there we go
there we go
yeah
yes
you did it
gorgeous
what are you thinking
i feel like i just
still also want a little
i like my i'm kind of like a
perfectionist about my plating like i'm
a nut ball in the kitchen but i want it
to like
i want people to be like god that chick
is nuts but then
at the end be like oh it doesn't look
crazy it makes sense or it doesn't look
so bad so it's important to honor the
plating process and the food oh you and
i did take a very different approach
though but it's fine it's you can do it
whatever way you want you know
i also think this was the wrong size
plate to begin with i wanted a full plug
that's why i portioned it out like it
should be a full blade
cheers cheers cheers to you eddie i'm
so grateful
to be sharing this moment with you i am
such an admirer i'm such a fan thank you
i have cyber stalked you you're also an
incredible advocate
um
for your home in lebanon i feel like
i've learned a lot about your home
through your advocacy so thank you for
all that you do in your community here
in brooklyn as well as back home
that means a lot for you to bring that
up that means a lot truly thank you
[Music]
you